[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's my pleasure to introduce kelly
wagman who came to cms from brown
university where she majored in computer
science
and economics and who after cms
is headed on to the university of
chicago to work on a phd in computer
science
in between she worked for several years
as a software engineer at microsoft and
after coming here to mit
as an ra in both the global media
technology and cultures lab
and in the open documentary lab where
she's a joy to have three things to add
kelly is uh incredibly productive has
authored a co-authored four
peer-reviewed
papers and several more are in the
pipeline so
um second our badly missed colleague
lisa parks is also
advising uh kelly and we're both kelly
and i both grateful to her for her
continued engagement
and on a personal note uh week in and
week out our meetings have proven to be
the high point of my calendar
i've learned a ton from working with
kelly i'm grateful for her
intervention which we'll hear about in a
second and inspiration
she gives me confidence in the future
kelly
thank you so much what an intro um
okay well i guess i will hop in let's
share
all right um do people see my screen can
someone just thumbs up
yep so um
like quebec said my talk is titled sex
power and technology
a relational engineering ethos as
feminist utopia
um so actually william covered this a
little bit but i wanted to just
say that i am coming from a
a particular vantage point that has
really informed my research so
i identify as a white cisgender woman i
grew up in the us
and i spent several years as a software
engineer at big u.s tech companies
um i think that there are a lot of
different ways to think about the tech
industry
a lot of people think about this image
at the top you know
kind of a hacker alone in a basement um
before i got to college i really thought
it was more like the middle like i was
going to be building these kind of
magical things
and when i got there i realized it was
actually more like the image on the
bottom
where you know guys stood around in
hoodies fixing bugs
this is a picture from the tv show
silicon valley which actually felt
pretty accurate
and this is me with some of my teammates
from a few years ago
so this project really came out of
needing language to explain this
experience that i had of being kind of
one of the only women in my context and
also
like this mismatch between what i felt
like the tech industry could be
and what i actually experienced while i
was there
so in tech a lot of people ask what we
can build but it seems less common to
ask what we should build
and this is the question that really
underlies a lot of my research
um the word should brings with the moral
and political questions that are hard to
answer from within an engineering
framework
so before looking at what we should
build i wanted to start by trying to
understand
what we are building i found that
silicon valley
and the tech cultures that are
influenced by silicon valley have a
particular way of thinking about the
world
this has been sometimes called the
californian ideology which was a term
coined in 1995 by barbaric and cameron
and there are a number of good books on
this topic here are just a few of them
so some of the main ideas from behind
the californian ideology
are one that it has this unique history
that was born from a convergence of
cultures
in the second half of the 20th century
including hippie counterculture
libertarian ideology funding from the
government for world war ii
and the idea of cybernetics there's also
a turn
from computers as actual women to
computers as being mostly men because
the work was originally deemed menial
and then became thought of as something
kind of difficult and complicated um
nathan enzemager talks about this idea
of extreme masculinity in the culture
for example staying up all night to
program
something is kind of a show of strength
it's very much built around capitalism
things like venture capital funding
provide incentives to startups to
maximize profit and scale
there's an underlying logic of kind of
rationalism where many products focus
on emphasizing optimization
efficiency productivity and there are
also strands of neoliberalism that
emphasize the individual and
apps that work for self-actualization
and self-improvement
so there's been a lot of good work
talking about why the california
ideology is somewhat flawed
i think royal's presentation did a good
job talking about some of these
um so i'm not really interested in
critiquing the existing state of the
world i'm more interested
in trying to understand what would a
different culture different ideology
around creating technology look like
so before diving into that i want to
talk about a few groups that are already
trying to kind of think about how do we
erode
some of these ways of thinking um
i found that really the groups that are
doing this are doing really important
work that i really support but often
they're not quite fully helpful to
designers who are looking for kind of a
vision
of what else they could be building so
there are diversity and inclusion
organizations which tend to focus on
improved representation within the
existing culture
that are not typically working to
actually change the culture
tech activists use labor tactics to
protest unethical technology and bad
working conditions particularly for
contract workers
however they often also don't provide
kind of a vision of what to build it's
often here's what we should not be
building
academics are wonderful at critiquing
the existing state of the world and
provide a lot of really valuable insight
but this insight is often hard for
people in engineering to understand
and needs to be translated into
something that's more generative
art pieces um actively build up ideas
for new worlds using technology but i
think can be dismissed by people in
engineering because they
are seen as kind of one-off are not
applicable to product development
and finally participatory design
co-design and other methodologies i have
found really inspirational and have
really influenced my work but
the methodology alone despite providing
a way for communities to build things
together
doesn't again quite outline like what is
the vision
of the thing that should be built
so i'm proposing something that i call a
relational
engineering ethos um my kind of
oversimplified way of
explaining the difference between that
and the california ideology
is i think of someone in the california
ideology context saying
i'm going to change the world for the
better and get rich by making a highly
scalable startup that optimizes
something
whereas in the relational engineering
ethos we think about
i can have lasting impact and develop
lifelong friendships by considering the
relationships formed throughout the
entire
lifecycle of my technology i'm
prioritizing caring relations over
profit and scale
so i'm gonna unpack that a little bit
one concept that's important to start
with is this idea of a feminist utopia
so traditional utopias run into problems
because they're usually
static visions that are defined by a
singular expert
which can lead to totalitarianism
however in contrast
feminist utopias allow for multiple
visions
and are more process oriented and
inclusive of many voices
the other kind of important concept here
is the idea of a socio-technical system
so often in the tech industry people
think about a product as a singular
thing
and kind of how do we build it and what
is the user experience
so for example you can think about the
amazon echo
you might think about how do we program
it and how are people going to use it in
their homes
but as crawford and julia show in this
image you can actually think about a
technology as like a web
of different socio and technical systems
so
excuse me we have um on the left
like what are the minerals that have to
be mined to create
the object what is the data processing
and labeling that goes into creating the
machine learning algorithms
and finally once the thing is disposed
of how how is it going to break down and
how is that going to affect the
environment
so we're shifting our thinking from
thinking about the object
as the singular artifact of thinking
about it as this web
embedded in a social system
so to come back to this idea of
relational engineering i'm proposing it
as a feminist utopia because
it isn't a singular vision but more a
way of framing
the problem of building new technology
and i'm using the idea of a
socio-technical
socio-technical system as a framework um
the ideas behind relational engineering
aren't new there
are many books that kind of talk about
this
style of thinking but the goal for me
was to kind of understand how do we wrap
up these ideas
in a way that is makes sense to people
in the design world
and for people who probably aren't
actually going to go read like hair away
on their own
so a few of the important concepts are
emphasizing building caring
relationships between humans and
non-humans as opposed to building
neutral artifacts
seeing interaction is situated within
these messy socio-technical systems as
opposed to a problem to be solved or
optimized
considering technology is co-creating
experience so avoiding the human
domination over
the technical artifact and holding space
for two new technologies that are
perhaps inefficient
meandering sensual not necessarily
optimized
and there's a lot of feminist literature
on these concepts of care
love and joy which i am not going to go
into in depth right now
okay so let's think about a couple of
case studies that kind of highlight this
way of thinking
um if we think back to that map of the
socio-technical system you can
understand that there are relationships
at many different scales
and we can kind of zoom in on just one
of them so here i'm kind of thinking
about how do we zoom in
on the relationships between teammates
in an engineering group
so i wanted to understand what these
relationships could look like in a
culture that was not part of the
dominant silicon valley culture
so i did participant observation at a
self-described feminist data science lab
where i attended weekly meetings and i
also interviewed
nine women and non-very binary engineers
from a range of universities and jobs to
try to get a sense of
what this alternative culture could look
like
[Music]
so the first thing i want to talk about
is how my participants
described feeling within the dominant
culture
so this is a graduate student who said i
think a stereotypical technical
university student
is kind of a nerd but it's also someone
who has a lot of privilege but isn't
very good at dealing with that privilege
after graduating i would make the most
money working in tech but that kind of
industry culture wouldn't make me happy
anymore
second an undergraduate student i talked
with who was in a class said
my partner was a dude with a fancy
terminal with customized colors and he's
like telling me
to type things i'm just like sorry can
you say that again i probably made a
mistake
and he got really impatient and i got
stressed out it made me feel very on
edge and like maybe that i didn't have
enough experience but then later in
class
we were working on the actual problem
and then he didn't know what was going
on because he didn't do the reading
i do the reading it's made me think we
try a lot harder to feel like we belong
and we still feel like we don't even
though we're more than qualified
so the important thing here is that both
students describe feeling like they
didn't fit into a culture
but they also talk about how they have
the technical skills
so this is not a story of people not
having the right skills it's a story of
people feeling like they don't fit into
a particular culture
another phrase that i heard in my field
work quite frequently was this idea of
technical versus non-technical
or technical meant pertaining to math or
code whereas non-technical was kind of
everything else the technical within
this culture is very much
masculinized and valorized um
and i noticed a phenomenon that i
started calling technical peacocking
where
my participants described usually men
who would kind of show off their
technical skills in a group as a display
of mastery
and kind of an attempt to be at the top
of this hierarchy
um my participants all said they were
not interested in engaging in this kind
of behavior
and one said guys are typically way more
technically oriented
i've seen that in this capstone project
women are like oh
i'm not that technical so i can work on
outreach slide templates or graphics
so she goes on to talk about someone
who's really excited about like the
mechanics of sand and she kind of
realizes that that is really you know
valued in this culture but she herself
doesn't quite get
like why someone would want to be so
excited about the mechanics of sand
um so we can see this kind of gendering
and different kinds of labor that is
valued differently within the culture
um so the point i want to make is that
it is not my interviewees that needed to
be changed or taught how to code better
but the culture that needed to be fixed
i really like this quote from
stephanie dinkins who says once we get
to the table either we're warriors
or we come with all these assumptions
already embedded so
she means that most marginalized people
who survive in the tech industry
are forced to become warriors in order
to do so and what i'm arguing is that
basically people shouldn't be forced to
do that we should change the culture
so how do you do that exactly um
uh there's actually a lot of literature
on how so-called feminist groups
actually end up being oppressive so it's
really important to focus on not the
word feminists but the practices and
norms that i found within the group
specifically
um so these are kind of the things that
the group did that i thought
made made the culture really welcoming
and inclusive
um overall the practices are relational
and the lab really focused on
building strong and caring relations
among members
so i'm just going to go through them
kind of quickly
first we have micro affirmations as
opposed to microaggressions
one example is putting pronouns and zoom
names
second we have collective decision
making and embracing ambiguity
so for example the lab co-created a
handbook that explicitly welcomed people
from different identity groups
and also really rewarded questioning
more than kind of being right
so there was no showing off of technical
knowledge
valuing social intelligence and lived
experience meant that people could bring
their full selves to the lab
they would take time to introduce anyone
new
even if it meant you know reintroducing
people that had already been introduced
and proactively engaged in conversations
about social justice
researcher trauma and current events in
order to check in on members and see how
to support them
finally the lab really emphasized
experimentation and joy as
important parts of the research process
so whereas
in some groups it may be that you're
totally focused on
productivity and producing like a number
of papers
or some kind of quantitative output
things like
producing zines as research outputs um
to kind of highlight how members could
be involved in ways that they were
really excited about
what's important so this kind of stands
in contrast to some of the experiences
people had in the dominant engineering
space
so i liked this quote from the lab pi
who i interviewed who said
people do their best work when they feel
supported or trusted sort of like you
need iot infrastructure you need
emotional infrastructure in order to be
creative
i think it is very inhibiting to be in a
toxic environment and you're told you're
supposed to be creative but you're
always being told that you don't belong
in various ways
so i kind of wanted to end this case
study with a story that highlights this
kind of relation building
in the engineering team not only leads
to more diverse and inclusive teams
but also changes the kinds of
technologies that get built so
i met a sophomore undergraduate at a
hackathon i attended where she was
introduced to the idea of data feminism
when i interviewed her she told me she
didn't think she would take any more
computer science classes because she
had such a bad experience culture wise
but a few days after our interview she
emailed me to say that she had read the
date of feminism book and that she had
reflected on her time at the hackathon
and she had a couple of ideas um
she said that the the book really quote
deeply and great helped her understand
deeply ingrained power imbalances within
our data and technology systems
and then she goes on to outline two
different tech projects that she wants
to make based on her interest in raising
awareness about disability eating
it really struck me that here was
someone who went from basically giving
up
on working in tech just saying she
wanted to build out these two really
wonderful projects
um and it was just so clear that this is
not a story
of a pipeline problem where she just
needed to get better at coding or be
more confident
it was a story of finding an alternative
to the dominant way of thinking about
technology that she encountered in her
classes
and feeling validated in her ideas so i
think if we want people like her to be
leading our tech
efforts in the future we need to create
a tech culture that values
relationship building over things like
technical
okay i also want to cover one other case
study so
again if we think back to that map that
we saw earlier
with the different socio-technical
relationships you know this was kind of
zooming in on
relationships between teammates but we
could also think about
zooming in on the relationship between
um the person
and the artifact itself so a
human-machine relationship
so this i worked with lisa parks and we
actually have published this as a paper
you can read the whole paper at this
link if you're interested
so our research question was to ask how
designers should think about building
essentially robots we actually decide
that we don't like the term robot we use
the term social machine because the word
robot brings with it a lot of baggage
and assumptions about what it should be
and what it should look like
so ultimately we argue that when
designing a social machine you're not
really designing an object you're
designing a relationship
and we draw on a lot of background from
feminist science and technology studies
which i'm not going to go into in depth
but is in the paper
but i think this image is kind of
helpful in getting a sense of what we're
trying to talk about so this is an ad
from the 50s
that basically posits these technical
home systems as servants so it implies
kind of a human
domination over these systems and not
only imagining them as technical systems
but actually imagining them as people
so before getting into how we think
designers should think about building
this relationship we
looked at how um particularly
roboticists already think about
designing
this kind of relationship and we found
that there are these four categories so
people think about social machines as
tools
as human companions as animals and
creatures
and as slaves and we argue that each of
these is problematic in kind of its own
way
so tools are what lucy suchman calls
subject objects
meaning that like a car can be a tool to
get you places but often people name
their cars and talk to their cars
so the object is at once a subject
because people talk with it and engage
with it and an object because it's
something that kind of
does something but you you can't
you can't deny the fact that people
treat objects to a subject some of the
time
in terms of humanoid machines such men
outlines
the problem in creating what she calls
ideal organisms
so people tend to reproduce normative
standards and ideals when they create
something that looks like something they
already know about
so if you look at humanoid robots many
of them
also kind of reproduce these beauty
standards that we see around the world
um animals and creatures can have some
of that same problem
with the becoming an idealized organism
but um in addition we have a long
history of dominating animals
and kind of a fraud there's a fraught
human animal relationship that we don't
really want to replicate when we
move to machines um and finally we think
about slaves as essentially tools that
have been made to act like people
um but that the human has like full
domination over
and here we argue that allowing this
kind of relation of domination to exist
where someone can have
full control over this human-like object
is
just like fundamentally flawed and not
something that we should allow
so our proposal is that social machine
should be approached as what we
call a gentle and equitable others
meaning that we recognize that the
social machine has agency
um we think about it as existing in an
equitable relationship with a human and
we also think of it as an other
to humans and animals so instead of
trying to map it onto one of these
existing categories just accept that
it's like a new thing
and we run in these two these kind of
two
problems when you actually try to build
something based on that definition
um that we pose as challenges to the
design community
so first we think about
non-antiboromorphic figuration where how
do you make something that
doesn't replicate um human ways of being
and doing
um this is actually kind of hard because
like i said we talked to our cars and i
wouldn't really consider the car to be
anthropomorphic so
it's kind of an open question whether
it's possible to create something that's
fully not anthropomorphic
but we like this example by kelly dobson
who's an artist who made a blender where
instead of
blender is voice activated and instead
of talking to it in
kind of human speech she growls at it
in blender language and then the blender
responds and turns on
so it's kind of the human becoming like
the machine instead of the machine
becoming like the human
our other design challenge is mutuality
so we talked about this idea of an equal
relationship between humans and machines
it's also not clear whether that's
possible because um
humans make machines so can can you get
rid of that power imbalance it's not
not totally clear but this piece by
lauren lee mccarthy
really starts to investigate that where
she acts as
a digital assistant in someone's home
for about a week so you actually have a
human on both sides where
there's the person in the home and then
she's acting out the role of the digital
assistant
and they have to kind of navigate this
relationship and understand
what is an appropriate way to be around
each other and it's hard
and it's awkward and it doesn't really
solve the problem but it highlights kind
of what a hard problem it is to kind of
think about how
one would design that relationship
so this is not part of the paper with
lisa but i kind of experimented with
building my own social machine that
would try to experiment with some of
these
ideas so i call this ambi and
it's not anthropomorphic in the sense
that it is
geometric but it is kind of
anthropomorphic in the sense that i have
it kind of
expanding and contracting which makes it
kind of look like it's breathing i think
um it has some agency
in the sense that it if you're not
clicking on it it will kind of move
around on its own and leave
a trail but the human can also interact
with it
by clicking and moving it around so in a
sense you
and the machine are co-creating this
image
and finally i wanted to show that you
can make something that was interesting
but not
you know productivity efficiency focused
so there's no
goal there's no thing that ambi is
trying to solve or achieve
it's simply an interaction that you can
have and kind of explore
um and exist in kind of this ambient way
of being with media
okay so just to wrap up um i kind of
wanted to return to these two
simplified concepts the californian
ideology as
the i'm going to change the world for
the better and get rich by making a
highly scalable startup that optimizes
something
and the relational engineering ethos and
contrast
that says i can have lasting impact and
develop lifelong friendships
by considering the relationships formed
throughout the entire lifecycle of my
technology and prioritizing caring
relations over profit and scale
hopefully this makes a little bit more
sense after we went through the two
case studies um
and just to summarize i think nan
the point here is kind of that not alt
tech development needs to look like
silicon valley there are viable
alternatives that are more inclusive and
produce different kinds of technology
a relational engineering ethos is one
alternative that i've proposed that
encourages thinking about
building caring relationships as kind of
the foundation of the technological
process
i have presented two case studies one
looked at relationships among teammates
in a feminist data science lab
and the other looked at designing human
machine relationships and
i just want to end with you know this is
not like a solution to capitalism there
are a lot of other
big structures at play here but i do
think
reframing how people think about these
things
can lead to more interesting future um
ways of being in the world and i was
particularly inspired by a lot of the
students i spoke with who were excited
about some of these things
um so thank you a big thank you to
william and lisa
certainly couldn't have done this
without you and to many more people who
i don't
have time to name now but who definitely
made this possible
thanks so much kelly um and
now i'm going to open open to questions
yes scott yeah kelly great presentation
um
and and i feel like i learned a lot from
it i want to just
ask one question about um when you raise
sort of the concern of thinking about a
machine as a slave
um i get sort of the
that so from a moral perspective we
aren't we ought to be thinking about
anything as slaves
um and that that you know for in terms
of our own moral development that's
important
is there any implication that there's
some impact on the machi
the machine machine itself i mean in
other words
uh beyond sort of our own uh
moral development what what is the
reason to avoid thinking of
the machine as a slave i think that it's
twofold one the most important thing is
to try to yes get rid of these relations
of domination that
exist in the world um just as
kind of a principle that if you have
them in some places it's kind of a
slippery slope and
we have a history of thinking of things
that we don't consider human to be
slaves
including other people um so
it's i think there's an argument to be
made for just
like getting rid of that in general um
and i also think you can think about it
as a kind of de-centering of the human
as the primary
important thing in the world so while
you may say well it doesn't really
matter about the machines
you know you extend that to like the
environment and animals and
all these other things that we've spent
our history dominating that we've kind
of said well it doesn't matter about the
trees
um and so it's more of an outlook that
we should think about this system as
kind of like
all important and a whole and machines
are not part of that
and so how do we integrate them into
creating
the like power dynamics that we want to
see
thank you tl
hey kelly thanks so much shows it's it's
really it's been fun to see your
your trajectory um i kind of want to ask
a playful
question about this um and i'm gonna
channel a sherry turco kind of question
because i think the
the sts inflection of your project's so
interesting and i love it
one of the things i know uh turkle
fears and she writes about is that our
machines ask
us to love them and that's part of their
affective power but they can't love us
back
and so i wonder like if you extend your
argument
would be would it include actually
making that making machines that could
love us back like a full
a full realization of the relational
thanks
yeah you know we engage with this in the
paper a little bit and i've talked
actually a lot to sherry and um
it's a hard question i think that the
the point
that i've come to and thinking about her
work is that she really frames
the machine as a human and
thinks of it as a thing that we're
trying to make it human and we're trying
to make it love
in a way that is human and i think i
disagree
with that that i think that like we say
that the machine
should not be framed in a human way of
thinking about things and we should not
try to make machines that claim to love
in the way that humans
love but i think if we
if we can kind of get the capacity to
think of machines as their own
thing that have their own kind of sets
of properties then
i don't think that precludes creating
something where you and the machine have
a relationship
i just wouldn't model it off of a human
human love relationship
i love that answer thanks
all right lisa wonderful to see you
it's great to see you guys and i miss
everybody and um
super great to hear your presentation
kelly
um just like i'm really impressed by how
you've extended yourself
over the past two years and read so
much different types of material across
different fields
and it's just really inspiring to
to witness that and congrats on getting
accepted into university of chicago too
i think it's such a it's really
wonderful i wanted to ask a question
about the slide when you were talking
about shifting the dominant culture
and you you suggest multiple areas and
possibilities for
for that and one one area that i think
um i would like love to hear you comment
on that
wasn't on that slide was just um the way
that big tech companies based in silicon
valley
continue to insist that they're going to
self-regulate
to conform with labor laws and
make their their internal cultures more
diverse
inclusive and equitable but we see then
these high-profile cases like
what happened with timnit uh gebrew and
um
you know what the lawsuit going on with
chelsea glaston right now who was hired
um in connection with her pregnancy are
fired in connection
with the pregnancy um and so i'm just
wondering
i think you're going to be looked to as
an expert to also comment on these
more kind of corporate
politics in connection with what you're
suggesting
and so do you have any thoughts about
these kinds of circumstances and how the
concept of relational engineering
could be infused in these
california silicon valley type of
environments like do you
do you see hope for that or do you think
it just needs to be a kind of utopia
outside of these contexts given the
kinds of practices we've seen
happening yeah that's a great question
um i think i wanted to start from the
utopia outside of the context because it
was important for me
not to just get fully wrapped up in
fixing broken systems that are like
broken from the outset in my opinion
and to really think about if we did
start from scratch what would we want to
build
um however i think you're right that
this is kind of the state of the world
and a lot of these systems already exist
and the thing that i like about this
kind of relational engineering
mindset i think of it as kind of a
mindset is that i think any individual
engineer
could kind of apply it in a lot of
different ways to their own work
you know i could think of like
individual teams at some of these big
companies
trying to kind of learn from this
feminist data science lab and could
totally
you know apply some of these principles
and ways of existing
at the team level i think individual
engineers working on projects
could start to try to think about this
way of thinking
um in their own projects and maybe that
it's not
totalizing or that it really fixes all
of the culture but that if you
start fixing little things at different
scales especially as i'm i really am so
hopeful about like the next generation
of students
who are getting exposed to some of these
other ways of thinking you know once
they enter the workforce
it's not going to fix it like i said
it's not going to fix capitalism but
you get enough people planted and i
think that there can be
actual change
actually i'd like to ask it
[Music]
um i'd like to ask a question and that
is that
um you know your trajectory through this
program is one in which you were
developing a certain set of ideas in
um the experience of of
uh practice you came here
um with a a clear set of ideas that came
out of that
that experience um
produced this this work and are now
heading in the next step of your
trajectory to
um a phd program and i'm curious to
to hear a bit more about that next step
and
how this particular thesis project um
connects to you know what you foresee in
the coming years
yeah i think the part of going to
a phd program in computer science
was motivated by the fact that i feel
like i can
have more impact and more change from
within
that kind of vantage point than from
with outside
from without and i i kind of think of
myself as like a translator i feel like
there is so much great
critical work but i think it is just
really inaccessible
for people with an engineering
background for the most part and so
i really wanted to be able to like pull
it and try to make it make sense
um and yeah i mean i think i definitely
fit the kind of warrior mold where i was
like i'm gonna get through this because
i want to prove that i can do it and
i don't know it's like what are my
chances of actually trying to change the
whole culture
probably slim but you know
if i could do something even at the
department level in one school like that
would make me feel pretty good
thanks and we have one question from the
from the chat
from hannah varner what are your current
uh dissemination plans for this
framework
academic articles popular scientific
communication etc
thanks hannah uh it's a good question
um
i yes i would like to write for more of
like an undergraduate level audience and
try to figure out how to disseminate
particularly to i think like
undergraduate women and
marginalized groups in engineering
because i think so much of it for me was
understanding that
that this is a big structural problem
that like i wasn't the problem
that i didn't need to conform to this
way of thinking that i could
that like other ways of thinking were
valid but it's hard to know that
i think sometimes when you're very
overwhelmed by a particular way of
thinking
so yes i'm not sure precisely
what something along those lines